- [Voiceover] Hey everyone.
So, in the last video I was
talking about divergence
and kind of laying down the
intuition that we need for it.
Where you're imagining a
vector field as representing
some kind of fluid flow
where particles move
according to the vector
that they're attached to
in that point in time and as they move
to a different point the
vector they're attached to
is different so their
velocity changes in some way.
And the key question that
we want to think about is
"If you have a given
point somewhere in space,
"does fluid tend to
flow towards that point
"or does it tend to
flow more away from it?"
Does it diverge away from that point?
And what I wanna do here
is start kinda closing
our grasp on that intuition
a little bit more tightly,
as if we are trying to
discover the formula for
divergence ourselves, because
ultimately that's what
I'm gonna get to, a
formula for divergence.
But I want it to be
something that's not just
plopped down in front of
you, but something that you
actually, you know,
feel deep in your bones.
So a vector field like the
one I have pictured above
is given as a function, a
multi-variable function,
with a two-dimensional input,
since it's a two-dimensional vector field,
and then some kinda
two-dimensional output.
And it's common to write
P and Q as the functions
for these, the components of the output.
So P and Q are each just
scalar value functions
and you think of them as the components of
your vector valued output.
And the divergence is
kinda like a derivative,
where you might denote it by just div,
and in the same way that your
derivative, you have this
operator and what it does
is it takes in a function.
And what you get is a whole new function.
This div operator you
think of as taking in
a vector field of some kind
and you get a new function.
And the new function you
get will be scalar valued,
it'll be something that just
takes in points in space
and outputs a number,
because what you're thinking,
the thing that it's trying to do
is take in some specific
point with XY coordinates
and just give you a
single number to tell you
"Hey, does fluid tend
to diverge away from it?
"How much, or does it tend to
flow towards it and how much?"
So this is the kind of, the form
of the thing that we're going for.
So here what we're gonna
do is just start thinking
about cases where this divergence
is positive, or negative,
or zero and what that should look like.
So for example, let's say we
want cases where the divergence
of our vector field at a
specific point XY is positive.
What might that look like?
So one case would be where your
point, nothing is happening
at that point and the vector
attached to it is zero,
and everyone around it is going away.
This is kinda the extreme
example of positive divergence.
And I animated this in the
last video where we have
you know, all of the vectors
pointing away from the origin
and if you look at a
region around that origin,
all the fluid particles
kinda go out of that region.
And that's the quintessential
positive divergence example.
But it doesn't have to look like that.
It actually, I mean, you
could have something where
there is a little bit of
movement at your point
and then maybe there's
movement towards it as well
from one side, and vectors
are kind of going towards it,
but they're going away
from it even more rapidly
on the other side, so if
you think of any kind of
actual region around your
point, you're saying,
"Sure, fluid is going into
that region a little bit,
"but it's much more
counterbalanced by how quickly
it's going out."
So these are the kind of
situations you might see
for positive divergence.
Now negative divergence,
negative divergence.
Let's think about what examples
of that might look like.
Divergence of V at a given point
and you know, really it's
something that takes in
all points of the plane
but we're just looking
at specific points, so if
the divergence is negative,
well the quintessential
example here is that
nothing happens at your
point, but all of the vectors
around it are kind of
flowing in towards it.
And this is the thing where I animated,
where we took this and we
flipped all of the vectors.
And said, "Ah, there, if you
start playing the fluid flow,
"then the density in any
region around the origin
"you know, increases a lot,
all of the fluid particles
"tend to converge towards that center."
But again, this isn't the only
example that you might have.
You could have a little bit of
activity at your point itself
and maybe it is the case that
things do flow away from it
a little bit as you're going away.
And some of the fluid
particles are going away,
and it's just the case
that the fluid particles
flowing in towards it
from another direction
heavily counterbalance that.
Cuz then if you're looking
at any kind of region
around your point, you say
fluid particles are coming in
quite rapidly, a lot
of particles per time,
but they're not leaving too
rapidly round the other end.
So kind of loosely,
intuitively, this is what a
negative divergence case might look like.
And finally, another case that
we wanna start thinking about
as we're tightening our
grasp on this intuition
is what happens, or
what does it look like,
if the divergence of your
function at a specific point
is zero, right, if it's
just absolutely zero?
And one thing this could
look like is, you know,
you have something going on
but nothing really changes
and all of the fluid just kinda
flows in then it flows out
and on the whole it balances.
You know, if you take any kind of region
the amount flowing in is balanced
with the amount flowing out.
But it could also look like
you have fluid flowing in
kind of from one dimension,
but it's cancelled out
by flowing away from the point in a manner
that sort of perfectly balances
it in another direction.
So these are the loose pictures
that I want you to have
in the back of your
mind as we start looking
for the actual formula for divergence.
And what I'll do in the next video or two,
is start looking at
these functions P and Q
and thinking about the
partial derivative properties
that they have that will
correspond with, you know,
these positive divergence
images that you should have
in your head, or the
negative divergence images
that you should have in your head.
So with that, I'll see you next video.